das pfarrhaus globig in sachsen anhalt
hat schon bessere zeiten erlebt
es wird eingeheizt denn gleich trifft
sich hier die seniorengruppe wie jeden
mittwoch allerdings bald ist damit
schluss pfarrer jürgen hofmann muss das
pfarrhaus aufgeben
es ist niemand mehr da der sich um den
maroden altbau kümmert glaube ich haben
wir jetzt das problem dass die mieter
ausziehen und wir haben das ist ein haus
wo die fenster neu sind das dach neu
sind aber eben keine heizung drin ist
das ist ganz ganz schwer neue nachmieter
zu finden dieser zeit dass wir uns
entschlossen haben das haus zu verkaufen
ein pfarrhaus macht zu das erlebt
hofmann nicht zum ersten mal
diesmal wird es wenigstens eine ersatz
bleibe gäbe er hofft dass die kleine
gemeinde zusammenhält und setzt dabei
auch auf gottes hilfe
[Musik]
das ist sowieso etwas was gott ganz oft
tut dass wir dass er uns die wünsche für
die wir ganz tief im herzen haben
aber es kann man immer weniger gläubige
zu den gottesdiensten und andachten der
leiblichen genuss mit stachelbeeren und
käsekuchen für den fahrer ein probates
mittel um luthers lehrern zu vermitteln
ja das war jetzt glaube ich wir gehen
jetzt im nachbarort nach wartenburg da
trifft sich damit ein kreis um halb vier
das schaffen wir gut und dann geht es
wieder weiter fulltime job zwischen
seniorenkreis und mütter gruppe sieben
tage die woche über 30 kilometer
erstrecken sich die dörfer der
kirchengemeinde sankt petri die nähe zu
wittenberg bringt nicht viel nur
ungefähr jeder zehnte ist hiernach
mitglied der evangelischen kirche
einstmals wiege der reformation heute
eine gottverlassene gegend gottverlassen
nicht aber den gegen hat gott vergessen
jedenfalls in weiten teilen der ddr war
ja nicht sehr erfolgreich besonders
wirtschaftlich nicht aber in der politik
der religions- bekämpfung warenqualität
er leider sehr erfolgreich und die last
haben wir jetzt dadurch zu tragen der
mütterkreis in wartenburg er ein
großmütter kreis die töchter und
enkelinnen fehlen viele junge frauen
verlassen die region um anderswo zu
arbeiten und die sind man dann sieht man
dann auch nicht werden doch wenn sie den
ruf informationen hatten das ganz selten
dass dann noch einmal den kommt traurig
es ist so
500 jahre nach der reformation in
wittenberg ist in der region nicht viel
übrig von der idee der kirche für das
ganze volk das volk interessiert sich
nicht wenigstens den kontakt zum
nachwuchs nicht verlieren dafür ist
hofmann vorsitzender des cvjm wittenberg
des christlichen vereins junger menschen
immerhin hier hat das lutherjahr einen
schub gebracht aus einem sommer projekt
ist ein dauerhafter jugendtreff geworden
wir hoffen dass die kinder mal fragen
warum machst du das eigentlich
und dass man dann unsere mitarbeiter
sagen jawohl ich mache das weil ich an
gott glaube weil sich um kontakt zu
jesus habt ja und das vivaz was bedeutet
dass und dann kommen solche gespräche
der pfarrer sieht sich ohnehin nicht als
vorbeter für die schweigende gemeinde
sondern eher als trainer für diejenigen
die ihren glauben entdecken ganz im
sinne martin luthers wir hatten ja in
deutschland immer volkskirche gehabt das
heißt da war dieses ganze volk in der
kirche jetzt müssen wir anderes
paradigma bekommen wir sind die kirche
muss für das volk da sein das derzeit
nicht in der kirche ist
[Musik]
denn jeden sonntag aufs neue ist er mit
einer halb leeren kirche konfrontiert
pfarrer hofmann kämpft um jeden besucher
seines gottesdienst alle vier wochen
spielt die jugendband dann kommen immer
ein paar leute mehr als sonst in die
kirche und sie seien eben nicht nur zu
hören
ich bitte euch jetzt einmal die augen
jetzt zu schließen
lasst ein inneres bild entstehen von dem
was ich gleich vorlesen werde gott sitzt
auf dem thron und wird gepriesen heilig
heilig heilig ist gott der herr der
allmächtige herrscher der glaube bringt
den menschen zu gott so die lehre martin
luthers pfarrer hofmann kämpft 500 jahre
später darum dass überhaupt nach
menschen die botschaft des reformators
hören wollen